Well, good morning church, welcome.
Uh, if you are new to our church,
we're so thankful you'd be here.
We hope you can connect here and feel welcomed here
and part of what God is doing in our lives and your life.
Uh, and if you've been here for a long time,
we're also thankful you would be here.
If you are new, please stop
by the new here area out there in the lobby.
We'd love to meet you and get to know you that way.
Uh, go ahead and take your copy of God's Word.
Turn with me to the Old Testament book of First Samuel
just getting started in this sermon series called He
Shall Reign.
We're gonna look at chapter one of First Samuels.
We walk through this book together.
So First Samuel one, again, put that bookmark there.
We'll be there going forward.
All of us have desires, don't we? Yes.
Like the, the things that we long
to have happened in our lives, the things that we want, need
even like base desires, talking water and food
and community like with things
that we can't really survive without
and that God designed for us to have.
But also there's other desires in our lives like an intimate
relationship or a solid job or a house
or good grades or athletic success.
And all of those desires can go off track,
but those also can be good and rightly ordered.
Well, 3000 years ago, the nation of Israel also had desires
after being freed from slavery in Egypt,
then wandering the desert for 40 years
and then into the Promised Land they moved.
But things didn't always go well
as they walked that journey.
See, even in the land under God's appointed leaders called
judges, the nation declined morally
and spiritually to where the end of the book
of Judges says this.
Everyone did what was right in their own eyes.
It's how far they had gone.
And so the nation at that moment was longing for stability.
Again, they were longing for security again.
They were longing for safety and prosperity again.
Yet what we'll see is that they were looking
for those things in the wrong places.
The first narrative out of the box here in First Samuel
introduces us to a few of the stories, main characters,
but it focuses in on this woman named Hannah.
And it, it really puts her life forward as an illustration
of the nation of Israel.
And we watch Hannah and we can learn about their nation and,
and ultimately we'll learn in her life
how her desires were ultimately fulfilled in God alone
and how ours can be as well.
And so let's get our bearings as we enter this book.
Let's look at the first seven verses to begin with here.
This will give us some context as well.
There was a certain man, uh, by the way,
just these words are hard, so gimme grace, please.
Okay, there was a certain man of Ram Z.
There you go. Have that one at lunch discussed.
So we'll see, uh, of the hill country of Ephraim,
whose name was Elna, the son of GE Ham.
Who son of Elihu. Son of Tohu, son of z Anite.
Basically, this man was Elna
and he was from this town, Ramathan zine.
Okay, that's what we need to know. He had two wives.
The name of the one was Hannah, the name
of the other Panina.
Panina had children, but Hannah had no children.
That sets up a contrast, as we saw last week is important.
Now, this man used to go up year by year from his city
to worship and sacrifice to the Lord of hosts at Shiloh,
where the two sons of Eli, HNI
and Phineas were priests of the Lord.
On the day when Elkin has sacrificed, he would give portions
to Ben, his wife, to all her sons and daughters.
But to Hannah, he gave a double portion
because he loved her though the Lord had closed her womb,
an arrival used to provoke her grievously to irritate her
because the Lord had closed her womb.
And so it went on year by year.
As often as she went up to the house of the Lord, she used
to provoke her, therefore, Hannah wept and would not eat.
There's a lot of background we'll get from there.
But let's first look at the map.
So you need to orient us here as we go
through this, where we're at.
So this is a perspective of where all
of this was even happening.
That town, the long name
that verse one says Anos from is just west of Shiloh.
You can see Shiloh right there in the middle.
It's kind of, the town would be just west of
that in the open area out there about 15 miles away.
They would travel those 15 miles to Shiloh, as it says,
to worship, because Shiloh was
where the tabernacle was placed
whenever the people first entered the land.
Uh, many years before that.
It's where the Ark of the Covenant was.
It's where Israel had placed the place of worship.
So that's where Eli, the priest and his sons were serving.
That's where people would go to sacrifice.
That'll matter in the next few weeks with Eli and his sons.
But that's again where Elkin all was taking his family
to go to worship.
But again, our primary goal today is to understand
and to think about Hannah, this woman who
we see was one of his wives.
So, so to start with, what we need to do is feel the despair
in her life that this passage reveals to us.
You saw it right away. The contrast pen had children.
Hannah had no children. The Lord closed her womb.
You saw that twice, right? This is the picture,
it's painting of the despair.
Did you not feel it as you read through this, right?
Hannah was childless
and back then being childless was seen very negatively.
It was almost like you were, you were being cursed by God
or a God, in fact, being barren, not even able
to have children was even worse.
Not only that, she's face-to-face with this guy's other wife
who was apparently very fruitful.
And so there was this never ending contrast set up in her
life where she was always,
she couldn't get away from feeling
like she didn't measure up.
I can't do what you can do. I can't do this.
And that's actually, again, indicative
of the way Israel was feeling.
At the same time, Israel as a whole,
they were declining morally and spiritually.
And so what we would say is there was a
barrenness in the nation.
There was suffering in the nation as a result of
what they were doing.
They looked around then at all of these other nations,
and comparatively they were less than
these other nations had strong armies.
They were wealthy, they were less than.
And so what Israel started doing was desiring things
that could give them safety and stature with others.
I wonder if some of us might feel like Hannah today
or like Israel at that time.
And I, I don't know all the stories, but I know a lot.
But, but maybe you literally are childless.
You are unable to have children biologically
and and there's this, this lack you feel in your soul.
Or, or maybe it's like, if, if I can just get married, then
that's, that's gonna, that's gonna make my life fulfill it.
Or if you could just advance at work a little bit, then man,
safety and security
for your family is gonna be taken care of.
If I can just get to that next level,
Or If I could just get the part in the play,
or if I could just make the team then, then my, my status as
a peer in my school will be finally fixed and I'll be safe.
I've wrestled with this. So for me, I've,
I've allowed health to sit on that throne.
And for the majority of my life, I've been really healthy.
And if, if I'm healthy, if my family's healthy
and my kids aren't sick, then man, everything's good.
I'm, I'm fine. But as soon as any of those desires,
as soon as that one for me
or that one for you, any of those desires are not met.
What happens?
Despair. We,
We, we crumble, despair creeps in.
And so then what do we do in response?
We, We feel this lack, we feel this hurt.
What do we do in response? We look for a solution.
We try to manufacture an answer to the problem.
But what we see next in this passage is the futility
of man's solutions to that despair.
We, we feel the despair with Hannah.
We feel it in our own lives. We see the, the futility
of solutions that we can provide to that despair.
Just consider the futility of what is happening here.
You already saw it a little bit
with Elana giving Hannah a double portion of the sacrifice.
Basically, he gave her a double portion of food to try
to show concern for her life that she was lacking this part.
Which by the way, I was thinking about this.
It's really romantic, isn't it ladies?
Uh, I, I heard a commentator talk about this, that he,
he described elna as winking across the table
as he put a double portion of mashed potatoes on her plate.
You know, like there you go, right?
Don't you just swoon when you hear that ladies? No.
But in reality, this was an effort by a good godly man
to bless her to show that he cared for her condition.
He was trying to meet a need in her life.
There was just absolutely no way That what he was trying
to do could fill that hole in her heart.
It's actually the same thing we see in verse eight.
Look at this. We continue on.
He says, Elana, her husband said to her,
Hannah, why do you weep?
Why do you not eat? Why is your heart sad?
Am I not more to you than 10 sons?
Basically, if the food's not cutting it,
maybe then he could be enough for her.
Like he's the hero husband coming to the rescue.
Like, am I not enough
Now he does seem like a good dude, but,
but would a relationship be enough for her?
Would
It be worth more than 10 sons to her?
No, Because the desire of her heart was
to have a son because the shame
and social stigma that came
with being childless would then be removed if she had a son.
It's similar to Israel trying all kinds of other ways
to cover their shame, to recover the stability
and prosperity and safety that they once had.
But now they've lost it. They tried everything they could.
The entire book of judges again, right
before this one, the entire book
of judges is one long narrative about the people turning
away from God and to other idols, to other gods.
This futile search for fulfillment that they could never
satisfy, satisfied, it never delivered on its promise.
It was never enough. Again,
isn't that the same for us today?
We are surrounded by a culture
that tells us we're lacking something.
Every one of us, every commercial, you're lacking something.
I'm lacking something. Every ad is I'm lacking something
that then creates despair in my life, which then leads
to finding solution after solution.
If only you had a better education,
if only we had a bigger house.
If only you had a, a husband that loved you,
if only you had a wife that respected you.
If only the, if only, if only, right?
That's a solution after solution.
Some people try those things.
Other people try solutions to numb the pain,
to numb the despair, drugs, alcohol, all kinds of
pleasure seeking just to, to make it go away.
We can even handle God like this,
where we seek solutions.
'cause deep down we know we're sinners,
and deep down we know that God is not happy with the way
that we've lived our lives.
So we seek solutions.
We, We clean up our life a little bit.
We go to church more. We try to stop cussing.
We give some money.
We, we try to throw our phone away for a while,
but then we just dig it back outta there.
Like we, we just try solution after solution.
But listen, as good as those things might be in our lives,
they are not the answer to life's shame and guilt.
They're futile in the end before a holy God.
And here's what those solutions do,
even the religious solutions, they lead
to desolation.
And we see it here that, that those efforts Israel had
to try to cover their shame led
to the desolation of their faith.
All of judges leading up to what we see here,
even in chapter one.
Notice the desolation of faith in Israel at this time.
Let's continue reading in the story.
Look at verses nine through 14, After they'd eaten
and drunk in Shiloh, Hannah Rose.
We'll come back to that Now.
Eli, the priest, was sitting on the seat beside the doorpost
of the temple of the Lord.
Hannah was deeply distressed
and prayed to the Lord and wept bitterly.
And she vowed of vow
and said, oh Lord of hosts,
if you'll indeed look on the affliction of your servant,
remember me and not forget your servant,
but will give to your servant a son, then I will give him
to the Lord all the days of his life.
No razor shall touch his head.
As she continued praying
before the Lord, Eli observed her mouth,
Hannah was speaking in her heart, only her lips moved
and her voice was not her.
She was praying quietly.
Therefore, Eli took her to be a drunken woman.
And Eli said to her, how long will you go on being drunk?
Put your wine away from you.
So I've already talked about the spiritual wasteland
that Israel was at that time.
There was rampant sin, abuse, idolatry,
all over the book of Judges.
We looked at that a couple years ago, right?
There is so much happening there,
but we'll see it again later in Eli with his sons.
We'll see that in a couple of weeks.
But even here, Right Eli,
this supposed priest of God,
he thought this woman praying quietly at the
tabernacle was drunk.
Had he not seen it before?
Like has it been that long since
you've seen somebody pray like this?
Or was he just whatever?
We don't know exactly,
but if he was truly tapped into the Lord,
if he was truly hearing from God as a priest,
this woman's uncommon devotion would not have
been a surprise to him.
He would've encouraged instead of criticized.
But listen, that was the state of Israel back then.
That was what was happening back then.
Eli was a miniature of what the nation was experiencing.
There were very few prophets.
There were very few ways that,
that people were genuinely following God.
That was a shock when devotion happened
because of the desolation of of Israel's faith.
It's the same thing that you and I taste
when we run away from God,
Isn't it?
Here's the truth. Sin always over promises
and under delivers.
It will never fulfill what it says it's going to.
It always over promises and under delivers.
It will never satisfy what we think it will satisfy.
And God will often let us walk through the heartache
and carnage of our decisions
because he wants to remind us that we were designed
to need him not to run away from him.
Because that's what God was doing here in Israel, right?
That's what he was doing here where,
where he was setting up a new day, a time
to draw his people back to himself.
They'd run away for so long.
Now he's saying, Nope, it's a new day.
I'm coming to you to bring you back to myself.
And all over scripture that often happens
through a miraculous birth.
This fresh start, this kind of new day happens
We see it with Abraham, we see it here.
We eventually see it with a virgin birth.
That's where this story shows up a number of times
as God's saying, Nope, here's a fresh start.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna start anew.
Here's a baby, I'm gonna start anew.
Here's a baby till Bethlehem 2000 years ago.
We get the final fresh start.
But here's what that means for us.
As we experience desolation, as we experience hard times
struggle, This means we should not run
away during those times.
Because what God is probably doing is he's using that
to bring about something beautiful.
He's opening the door to something powerful.
He's Saying, I've got something new.
Here's what's coming.
So don't run away in that because that's what we see next.
Even in this spiritually dark land that Israel was,
God uses the uniqueness of Hannah's faith here.
God uses the uniqueness of Hannah's faith.
See it here, right? In the contrast to
what Eli was like in contrast to
what the judges were like in contrast to all of that,
look at how Hannah is faithful.
Look at the first part of verse nine again.
I said, we'll come back to this after they'd eaten
and drunk, meaning after they'd worshiped in Shiloh,
Hannah Rose.
Now to us, we read that
and we think, okay, well she was sitting on the floor
and just got up.
Is that like what? What's the big deal?
Well, in the original language, that word brings
with it a conviction,
a settled disposition.
There's something that changed
In Hannah.
See in the storm of her rival provoking her.
God worked in her heart.
She didn't run away away in the desolation.
She allowed God to work in it in her.
And so she went to the temple.
She was still grieving, still hurting.
She still didn't have a son.
But did you see her prayer in verse 11?
Did you see her vow to the Lord? Look at it again.
She vowed vows, said, oh Lord of hosts,
if you'll indeed look on the affliction of your servant,
remember me, not forget your servant,
but will give your servant a son.
I will give him to the Lord all the days of his life.
And no razor shall touch his head
like she knew God cared for her.
She knew God heard her, that he was listening
and he was, he was with her.
And so she was so committed to him
that she didn't even need to have
that desire fulfilled anymore.
Did you see that? How different this was?
Because what she say she would do with the Son,
if God did happen to give her a son, what would she do?
She would dedicate him to the Lord's service.
What she's referring to here is called the Nazarite vow.
You saw it with Samson, you saw it
with John the Baptist in the New Testament,
this Nazarite vow that they would not cut their hair.
This was a commitment to serve the Lord.
They wouldn't drink wine, doesn't touch any dead animal.
They would serve the Lord with their whole life.
And it was an indication
of set apartness that they're different.
There's something unique here.
And she was saying, my son, if you give my son
to me, I'm gonna give him to you.
He's all yours. Like, don't miss this.
Don't miss Hannah's faith.
She had such faith in God that she was willing
to give up this fulfillment of her desire
because she was so satisfied in God himself.
You see that she
was so satisfied that she was willing to give up this child
that she'd prayed for and,
and did you see, she wasn't even upset about it.
You remember the, the story of the rich young ruler came up
to Jesus and he did all this stuff.
And he's like, yeah, I'm, I'm right, right?
Jesus, what else do I need to do? And
Jesus is like, you gotta sell everything.
Give to the poor and come follow me. And he went away
Sad. It says
He wasn't willing to give up everything.
He didn't see Jesus as his treasure.
He saw his treasure as his treasure.
But, but look at this. Look at the end of verse 18.
The woman went her way. Hannah went her way and ate.
And her face was no longer
sad, this commitment.
And she's willing to give him up. She was no longer sad.
We'll see this next week as we look at her at her song,
she prays in response in chapter two.
We'll see it next week. That there is a deep
rooted joy in Hannah.
Now, something is different in the storm
of being provoked, something is different.
Why was it different? Because she trusted God in the middle
of a difficult, impossible situation.
In spite of that, she had faith in him, said, God,
you're who I trust.
You are who I want.
This plot line throw shows up throughout the Bible
where in the face of opposition, the face of struggle,
God uses the faith of one man
or one woman to bring something about that he wanted to do.
It's all over the place. Joseph right sold into slavery.
God be uses him to be the savior of his fa family.
Bring him to Egypt, save their lives, his whole nation.
Moses led his people outta slavery,
led them into promised land,
right towards the promised land.
That's what God did through the faith of Moses,
even when everybody else didn't wanna do it.
Joshua, Caleb,
they trusted God would give them the land in the face
of giants and massive armies.
They said, no, our god's bigger than that prophet
after prophet standing as lone voices in Israel,
calling their people back to God.
Mary scorned
by the world, believing God could use a humble
virgin to carry the savior of the world.
Even Jesus who was walking that journey at the end alone,
carrying the weight of our sin, trusting his father's will.
God uses that to change eternity for those who believe.
Right? So the faith, the unique, even if it looks crazy,
the unique faith of one person, God uses that
to change the story.
He does it for Hannah. Where Samuel becomes the prophet.
We'll see in the next few weeks that changes the course
of Israel, the faith of a woman.
God used to change everything.
See, God never promises that our lives will be easy.
Never promises that we'll get everything that we ask for
that we would long for.
But he does say that when we trust him in the middle of it,
that's where he shows up.
That's how he works. No matter what we're facing,
God says, trust
Me. And
he works through that 'cause.
That's what Hannah got to experience.
That's what she got to see.
Look at this, the grace of God's provision.
She got to see it. She got to cherish it.
The grace of God's provision in her life.
Look at verse 14 again, down through verse 18.
Eli said to her, how long will you go on being drunk?
Put your wine away from you.
But Hannah answered, no, my Lord,
I'm a woman troubled in spirit.
I have drunk neither wine nor strong drink.
I've been pouring out my soul before the Lord.
Do not regard your servant as a worthless woman.
For all along, I've been speaking out of my great anxiety
and vexation, meaning I've just been troubled.
I've been hurt. I've just been praying outta my heart, man.
That's all I'm doing.
And Then Eli answered, go in peace. The God of Israel.
Grant your petition that you
Have made to him.
And she said, let your servant find favor in your eyes.
And the woman went away
And Ate. And her face
was no longer
Sad.
See, she knew that
God was gonna do what he said he was gonna do.
She believed that She had faith. She trusted him to do
That.
And look what happens next verses 19 and 20.
They arose early in the morning and worship before the Lord.
They went back to their house at Rama,
and Elon knew Hannah, his wife, and the Lord remembered her.
And in due time, Hannah conceived and bore a son.
And she called his name Samuel for she said, I've asked
for him from the Lord.
That's the name Samuel. That's what it means. Asked
Of God.
The baby I asked God gave
Isn't God good?
Like When we wait on the Lord,
When We trust him for his ways, for his timing in this,
he blesses his people.
This barren woman who'd been cast off from society.
Even in her own family, God gave her a son in response
to her faith-filled request to responding to her
satisfied joy in the Lord.
Again, it's similar to Israel, barren suffering.
They were waiting on God.
And then a, a prophet named Samuel was given to them,
which led to a model king
Named David being given to them, which
Eventually through that family led to the perfect
King named Jesus being given
Israel. Baron
waiting. God
Gave grace.
Yet, yet, I want you to see
something here in Hannah's story.
See, It wasn't that her joy was fulfilled
When she got pregnant.
Did you see that Her
Joy in God was fulfilled?
Then she got pregnant.
That's out of order to what we typically think.
And when God answers our prayer, then we're like,
yes, praise God.
Our joy is fulfilled. No, no, no.
She had her joy fulfilled in God first
and then she got pregnant later.
Again. Her deepest needs were
not met in the fulfillment of her desire.
Her deepest needs were met in the fulfillment of her desire
for God and Him alone.
More than a husband, more than one son, more than 10 sons.
It was fulfilled in God.
That is faith, that's rejoicing even
before you get the desire met.
That's what he's talking about here.
'cause look at how her prayer shifted. Did you see this?
Her prayer shifted where probably
before this moment was, God, give me a son
to make up this deficiency in my life.
I need a son. I'm getting chastised
by my peers, by my family.
God, give me a son to make up deficiency.
Now notice, God, you are all I need.
Give me a son so he can be yours.
See that God gimme a son so he can be yours. That's a shift.
And we see it play out here in the last section
of chapter one.
Look at verses 21 through 28.
The man, Elena and all his house went up to offer
to the Lord the yearly sacrifice to pay his vow.
But Hannah did not go up for, she said to her husband,
as soon as the child is weaned, I'll bring him so
that he may appear in the presence of the Lord
and dwell there forever.
She was committed to her vow Elkin, her husband said to her,
well, do what seems best to you.
Wait till you've weaned him.
Only may the Lord establish his word.
She He, he agreed with her.
And so the woman remained and nursed her son
until she weaned him, which was about 3-year-old.
3, 3, 3 years old.
At the time when she'd weaned him, she took him up
with her along with probably three bulls, an iffa
of flour, a skin of wine.
And she brought him to the house of the Lord at Shiloh.
And the child was young.
They slaughtered the bulls
and they brought the child to Eli.
And she said, oh my Lord, as you live my Lord,
I am the woman who is standing here in your presence praying
to the Lord for this child.
I prayed, and the Lord has granted me my petition
that I made to him.
Therefore, I have lent him to the Lord as long
as he lives, he is lent to the Lord
and he worshiped the Lord there.
So again, the point for Hannah was
that her faith in God was so deep that
that she was willing to take that three-year-old,
cherished child
and leave him in the tabernacle to serve the Lord forever.
She knew this child was God's far more than he was hers.
And you know why she knew that?
Because she knew that she was God's too.
God's got me. God's got my child. This is his child.
This is not mine. I leave him here. She knew she was God's.
Did you see five times?
She referred to herself as a servant.
She said, God, I'm yours. I am your servant. I am yours.
Listen, that's what God is calling each of us to as well.
He's calling each of us just like he provided for Israel.
He heard and answered Hannah's prayer for a baby.
And in that he called them all to faith in God.
He's calling us to the same thing, to give the fullness
of our response to this king of kings and Lord of lords.
This is what he is calling us to give a full response to
what he has done
To who he is.
I mean, just think about it. Let's
play it out with Hannah for a second.
She could have come to the tabernacle
and taken this answered prayer.
She's having him in a, uh,
I don't know if they had strollers back then,
but she was carrying the baby, bringing the,
answered to this child.
I prayed, right? She's bringing the answered prayer
to the tabernacle,
and she could have merely offered the bulls and the wine
and the, the grain.
She could have said, here it is, God, here it is.
Here's the sacrifice I'm supposed to offer for this child.
And she could have seen that as enough, right?
But, but this is the child that you gave me.
But I'm gonna give everything else away.
But no, what'd she do?
She gave the fulfillment of
what she once saw was the deepest need in her life
as the way that her shame was going to be removed.
Her future was going to be secure by having a son.
She gave even that,
that was her true worship because it came from deep
Inside her heart, right?
It wasn't just the rituals, it wasn't just anything.
But seeing God as her highest treasure
and holding everything else loosely.
That's worship.
Is that where you are today?
Like I've had to wrestle with this question myself all week.
Is My response to God full
and complete from my heart?
Is yours Full and complete from your heart?
Or as we look at Hannah, as we look at Israel,
as we look at our lives, are you looking for security
and stability and prosperity in all kinds of other things?
Are, are you trying to cover your shame
and your brokenness with having kids or getting married
or having a lot of money
or sexual, inter, all of those things, like whatever it is.
Are you trying to cover up
what you feel is your deepest need
with all this stuff the world can offer?
Here's the truth, our real shame, our real brokenness con,
not from any of those things.
They come from the fact that our relationship
with God has been affected by our sin.
That's why we feel lacking. That's why we feel deep inside.
Some mistake has happened,
but that's the beauty of the gospel,
that Jesus was broken for us.
Jesus took the penalty of our sin for us.
He was forsaken for us, all of that so
that we could be restored back to God and have the shame,
and have the sin and the penalty and the wrath covered,
Which Would never be covered by anything
Else Other than a perfect
Sacrifice.
Therefore, Romans 12, one says,
Just like we saw, therefore here in verse 28,
therefore in view of God's mercy, in light
of all that he has done for us in his grace
and mercy, it says, offer your bodies.
Offer yourselves as a living sacrifice,
holy and pleasing to God.
This is your spiritual act of worship.
You see the parallel here,
the deepest need you have ever been facing
is not a lack here in this world.
The deepest need is right here in your heart, in view
of God's mercy
And grace.
Offer yourselves your whole selves as a living sacrifice,
Holy by God, pleasing to him by his own work.
This is your spiritual act of worship. That's what we're
Talking about.
That's what Israel's looking for.
It's what Hannah was looking for.
It's what we're looking for.